this is it this is the podcast we're in
it right now are we are you also
recording
i am recording look at us that means
this is it this is us doing a podcast
yeah
we're in the moment the whole 98 of them
i think i get out of the habit now now
we're doing them once every couple of
weeks like i i forget how to talk
it's kind of
this kind of venue right this episode
only takes two weeks for that to atrophy
yeah well because normally obviously i
because i have to put on this persona
because i'm obviously i'm most of the
time just yelling at my team yeah so
it's it's i have to kind of put on the
mike biffle yeah horribly abusive and
you have to trade horribly yeah famously
yes
famously so and you have the facial hair
which is not that it's a prosthetic
purely for purposes of the podcast you
guys can see this yeah this is put some
art up by the way and i noticed that
from the camera i put this
this that's austin and that's mike you
can't see troy because of the
perspective it's actually there actually
isn't troy or you in it it's just it's
just an image
yeah and then and then i put this one
from ollie up here as well because i'm
trying to that's cool i actually decided
that i'm gonna buy a canvas to cover the
electrical box and do something on it
myself
i like the amount of god of war art you
have as well that you've kind of
basically like created like the
stereotypical game development cubicle
in your own home it is my office so like
i'm i yeah that's good i told you guys
my i work from a desk that's right there
and i also have a tv there for the dev
kit that i've moved sure and then this
part is obviously content creation
perspective so it i do work from here as
well the god of war stuff is like i
didn't buy any of it
so there's a ps6 just over there there's
a playstation 6 right there
incredible yeah amazing yes
looks it's huge huge oh they always are
yeah yeah you know it makes sense um and
they have to fit in their fit in all the
you know the hologram components all
that stuff takes a lot of space yeah it
also strange choice they decided to make
the entire ps6 vibrate like the dual
sense yeah um just to add to atmosphere
in case you happen to be touching it
it's called the floor sense yeah it's
like a it's like a bass speaker it's
very good it's um and it's powered by
nfts of course
thanks sony this whole thing should be
one of those animated
bits
to like see the artist's rendering of
the vibrating
yeah very very big fan and he asked me
how god of war was going and i said
that's nda's shoe and that's that's that
was my favorite experience of the whole
thing
you passed the test i was telling shuhei
yoshida that i couldn't tell him
anything about god of war
there must be some kind of like
kind of like
chair chairman emeritus kind of you know
like you are you are lifetime
included
uh that even if his role changes i feel
like we're in public
we were in public though there were
people around well obviously yes
i wasn't going to answer the question
but i just mean i don't mean i don't
mean in in out of respect for his
time in the position that he had there
but like contractually it would be like
there is nothing we're allowed to keep
from you internally uh
at sony forevermore as part of your uh
tied to him at this point
he's very synonymous with the brand and
i also
i was saying this to somebody on my team
had my first um
press experiences
uh because obviously dice is not
any press really very little yeah um gdc
is and
it was very interesting and i also like
got the perspective shift of how so i
would sometimes ask
a dev or somebody
uh
a question that i knew was jokey that i
knew they wouldn't answer
and i think i got some of those and
getting those the other way around was
not as fun as i thought it's actually
just awkward
um and i was like
because you've got the boss who's told
you before you went in under no
circumstances can you kind of reveal any
of this
nobody said any of that to me i just
assumed i could i could have told
everybody everything technically no i
happen to be here people probably
rightly or wrongly assume that you have
a good grasp of like media training just
through i think so but i also obviously
because i was in media for so long have
a lot of media friends so they were
asking me like
somebody just asked me a question that
your friends just casually come up to
you like this so i'm just curious
how's everything going there i love i
love the idea that they've still got
like the like they've got
with the little uh with the little press
badge
and they have like a little hat with the
camera yeah
yeah they're prepared to hand the scoop
to a little kid and
like with with suspenders who's gonna
run off people may have asked me
[Music]
because they thought i would answer
maybe i don't i don't know but i got one
question that was like
uh how different is the axe this time
around and i was like
what
i do i can't answer that question and
they're like oh i just thought that no
what the [ __ ] no i can't answer any
question you would ever have for me
about this and like that one because it
was somebody i knew well i was like what
are you doing whereas the other ones
it's just like ha ha
well uh
yeah turns out
not as fun as i thought when i did it to
devs all the time
more just awkward and uncomfortable i
apologize
i had a version of that at gdc on behalf
of all other game developers
thank you it means a lot for that
my uh my sort of variation on that was
i've had a lot of
calls one on
uh over the pandemic as we all have
where obviously you're alone in a room
talking to someone alone in a room
on a
at least hypothetically secure
you know non-broadcast
um
connection and so you know like this one
yeah
go ahead yep
um
and so you know the exchange of
privileged information
um in conversation
feels like
it doesn't you don't think of taking
special steps beyond just the normal way
like if you need to have a conversation
with somebody that's confidential
including even for personal reasons like
just can i confide something in you kind
of thing
i think we've gotten so used to this
rhythm i had a moment
where i was talk i i had a meal during
gdc with with a friend
and i asked them
uh a question
not quite as egregious as your axe
question but a little bit kind of like
so i'm curious
you know xyz or whatever about the thing
that you're working on that
you know officially isn't announced kind
of thing
but we were at a restaurant um and it's
funny how even just me asking i felt the
person suddenly so aware of all the eye
and then it made me aware and i was like
oh yeah you're right this is and they
kind of looked around and was like
yeah maybe maybe we should talk on the
phone you can hear a lot of nd8
conversations around gdc like i had a
friend who works in pr who overheard an
entire
game that has not been announced at a
bar at gdc that she was like yeah
somebody works in pr i thought about
telling them to shut up but i was like
i'm just going to leave that
it's a really bad idea but again i think
a lot of people don't have media
training they don't no that's not even
media training that's just because we're
just out of practice it's like
well we're out of practice of just the
very idea of what being in earshot even
means because we've had two years of
that not being a fact of life
i also think um one thing that's cool
with games is often like the ridiculous
thing happens so i had it a dice where
there's a
i'm going to be very careful
there's a guy who i always will go up to
and i'll do
a joke because
he works at a company
and they make games obviously and you
know i'll ask oh when you're making the
next sequel to franchise x that i like
and it's a funny funny joke
it is a really funny joke you're gonna
just have to trust me on that
and this time it's right up there with
half-life three confirmed yeah please
assume all jokes i make are very funny
yeah yeah just from this point on from
this point on yeah if i stop talking and
smile please laugh okay please yeah okay
um
bush of finishers exactly yeah i was
just thinking that is jeb bush imagine
being famous for that one thing
um but though the um i'm keeping my mic
um but yeah so anyway went up to him
this this year and did that joke and he
looked awkward because clearly he is now
working on that thing
and it was there for kind of i basically
stepped in the exact same trap you did
but kind of in a way that's been
building for about eight years
that's that actually is good though i
like that i think but that means you
manifested it
i basically did
manifested i hate that we all stop oh my
god i hate it too i hate it too it
drives me nuts
pseudoscience i just [ __ ] this video
yesterday
someone was like have you manifested
today and i was like
the sun wouldn't have risen if i hadn't
so yes you're welcome wanting the thing
about people and then working towards
getting them if you call that
manifesting cool but if you just kind of
sit there and have a think about it and
you don't snatch in any of it no no it's
all about the secret stuff isn't it it's
that kind of idea that people who don't
have things they need are just not
trying hard enough to want them it's
like that seems like a very middle-class
adult kind of perspective on the yeah
well that always from at least from my
sort of half
analysis of it
is that what those things like the
secret inevitably leave out
is when you focus your goal and start
acting towards it then statistically
you're going to start sure seeing
results and by acting as though it's the
thought only as opposed to the fact that
you've now motivated an entirely
different
set of behaviors yeah that will cause
reactions you know like if i start
telling everyone
my favorite thing on the planet is video
games and i just go about my my life
as normal
statistically i will encounter some
person after a certain amount of time
that goes oh that's so i'm a friend
actually i went to university with who
works in video games and i could connect
you if you want and it's like i've
manifested this theoretic hypothetically
speaking i'm a success story of that
model but in reality it's also ignoring
the 99
percent of conversations that that
didn't but it that one percent
wouldn't have happened if i hadn't kind
of actually made it a conscious goal so
it's one of those motivated and sharing
your goals with people is fine it's this
idea that there's like a magical weight
to the universe that kind of well yeah
exactly
[Laughter]
you're gonna put you're gonna put a
title on it which is i don't know gdc or
something yeah
i don't know i'm gonna do that now
that'll be that'll be the name of the
youtube and then it will just be a one
hour this is the first episode somebody
else is named i'm writing that down it's
gonna be i don't know gdc american
spirituality
[Laughter]
i don't know it was it was an american
there wasn't like the victorian era who
kind of
the idea of like manifesting is like a
very specifically american spiritual
it was like they're there it's like
because it's titled
it goes that far back as somebody who's
nominated spirituals you can also tie
the idea of manifesting to
you thinking about something positively
and thus you feeling more positively
about it and thus you being more likely
to take action again i'm i'm with you
austin that i think it's just
statistically if you think this thing
and you you speak about this thing and
you do this thing the thing is going to
happen
you'll also recognize opportunities
like
because you know it's like everybody
who's ever shopped for something i
always use the example of buying a car
but it can be literally anything it can
be i'm i'm i'm in the market for new
sticky notes and as soon as you have
that at the forefront of your thoughts
suddenly you'll realize that thing
you're looking for is everywhere all
around you and you
notice it in a way that you tuned out as
ambient noise like if you're shopping
for a car the specific model that you're
interested in will suddenly be every
other car you see on the road
and it's one of those things that's just
we filter so much and as soon as there's
as soon as there's a sort of a
somebody who's trying or thinking about
getting a bmw i8 let me tell you i never
see them because i would love to because
i want to ask how people park because
they have that's a fancy
i need to look at myself in a mirror and
go manifest [ __ ] and then 19th century
by the way i looked it up it is it is
america the law of attraction um it's i
think it's where definitely comes out of
christianity
it was someone called helena helena
protrovna
blavatsky which sure you nailed it no
i'm sure i got absolutely perfect and
thomas i feel more comfortable
um that do this instead of going like
out they do this they just go up on the
sides and it's terrible design delorean
i think you just think you just want to
time travel i really like the car and um
my issue is that i i'm like how do you
park anywhere and get out and so i just
want to find somebody with that car to
be like excuse me sir tell me how do you
get out of this car if you're parking
just i just need it it must be reddit i
have looked it up on youtube and they're
all so forgiving because they're all
fanboys
so they're like yeah sometimes you just
you know it can be a little tough what
does that mean
sometimes you can't get out of your car
but it's a great car what does that mean
i don't i guess it just means don't park
in a compact spot
uh and yeah
or you can be one of those bros that
gets a car like that and just blatantly
straddles two spaces with a with a you
know i don't give a [ __ ] kind of let
everybody know i have a cooler extremely
hung yeah we like those those people are
really cool they're really yeah they're
always especially if you can also do it
on a handicapped spot really
just yeah
yeah really you gotta that's manifesting
you know that's like talking on my two
spaces and one of them is handicapped
i'm i'm going to manifest some new
people in my life
i'm going to get a lot of unsolicited
introductions i'm going to get some
scientists doing this behavior yeah
okay so manifesting by definition is not
actually what we are speaking about it
uh as in in this context it is
display or show a quality of feeling by
one's acts or appearance demonstrate
so you can manifest qualities towards
you can manifest a sign of severe
depression um but that would mean you
are depressed
um
so that's the first
it's almost a synonym of like exhibiting
it it doesn't necessarily yeah
exhibiting demonstrating uh otherwise
it's be evidence of or prove
which well no no not in the center are
you doing like the
literal definitions i think what i'm
saying is where the way we're talking
about it has evolved beyond these and
then the third one is become apparent
through the appearance of symptoms so
like a disorder that usually manifests
in middle age
um this is manifestation in the magical
sense of bringing something into being
this is the idea of like
what's it called the new something like
the
it's it's an american i think i swear
it's new american but it's this idea of
like laws of attraction if you put out
something into the world you can get
something back right that is used
largely by that's the secret it's used
largely by cult leaders basically to get
them people to send the money or at the
very least people who have a lot of
privilege like i just don't feel like
you can really make that stance unless
you if you don't have a lot of [ __ ] to
worry about
or you can or it can be a very uh uh a
very attractive stance if you're someone
who's in a really bad situation right
which makes you very easy to manipulate
by
you guys seen all the hillsong stuff
that's been going down
what's that
i believe it's hilton hill
that's what it's called right
i mean there's definitely a lot of like
american churches who do the whole like
send us a hundred dollars actually in
australia god will give
i believe actually started in australia
um
or new zealand i think i think it's
really i hope i'm thinking about the
right thing
basically just uh they're
like leader had to step down
um because he had
engaged in appropriate behavior with
two women and then another one got outed
and it just it just kept happening and
uh they did this private live stream
that uh david farrier the
i guess he would go as journalist you
know who he is uh made doc on netflix
um oh yeah again i think i know him
probably because he made dark that's
like the german show
no it's a documentary series david faria
again i think i may also say i don't see
how someone could remotely be
overlapping
uh
tourist
i just said doc uh it's a documentary
series oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
dark tourists the the movie i scored
that we talked about once it was not
supposed to be called documentary series
the thing people scrolled past to find
them
he's
so again maybe i only know him because
of the proximity whatever um he's pretty
well known but he found a
link to the
this meeting um and wrote up a full
transcript of it where all of these
people were so sad about this man who
assaulted women stepping down
and they're just their speeches because
they didn't realize it was going to be
public are also like
you know it's just it's such a tough
time for him and we feel so sad and it's
like jesus christ
um and they got charged by the cops etc
etc so that whole thing blew up
and yeah i guess he got a link to an
unlisted video on youtube with the note
please do not share this link
naturally he got the link there were
like
400 people watching i think
and it was the church's founder who was
charged by the police
for covering up his father's child sex
abuse
and for engaging in inappropriate
behavior with two women
um
wild so then yeah he just watched this
like and wrote a full article about the
breakdown of how the the church's
internal leadership reacted to the whole
scandal and it was truly terrible i'll
leave a link to the articles because
it's very interesting
getting a prize seems to be no shortage
of stories like that uh
it's i definitely that's one of those
the modern era has facilitated
catching those kinds of frauds in a way
like my favorite ever was the amazing
randy
um
you know
the skeptic uh
who who um went to the name of the
documentary we should put people into
that documentary i can't remember i'm
gonna look i'll look it up you carry on
but he he had a very famous thing where
he he uh
went to a big mega church uh faith
healer who was you know taking people's
money and claiming to heal them in real
time
and
uh and part of his shtick was not
knowing what their ailment was and being
able to predict it and making the crowd
gasp and randy went in there with what
was the equivalent of a police scanner
and was able to hear the guy's wife
pre-interviewing people and feeding him
radio
uh
tips uh like right before they talked to
somebody on a on a little hidden
earpiece
and went on like went on like johnny
carson
went public with it on a talk show and
he didn't like that was his way of going
to the press and publishing his findings
they literally played this video for the
first time ever on i think it was on
johnny carson wow he was always he went
and basically if there were if you were
someone making a claim of like some kind
of paranormal ability in public he would
go on like yeah like he'd go on like a
johnny carson and do your trick on stage
basically and and ruin it um yeah he
also had a million dollar prize in the
documentary
he did didn't need for someone who could
prove
a mystical act was it he was something
yeah it was like if you could
demonstrate the supernatural in a way
that's yeah you know reproducible
i mean it would it would have changed
yeah it would have changed
mystery that would have been amazing
though can you imagine that's the thing
i think with all of these people i think
i remember him saying as well in
interviews that like
he
he spent his whole life i think he he
died right he's he did recently yeah
recently he but yeah anonymous lives
documentary i think he says in that
documentary that like
no one wants to be proven the paranormal
more than him like he'd love oh yeah
exactly the real thing to someone to
show up with actual magical abilities
here's a incredible one
yeah here's a ghost
telekinesis do you think what he's doing
is
uh
good is is is his decision to do that
morally good
oh my god i think i think magical
thinking hurts more people than many
many diseases do i think the idea of
like
faith or belief in nonsense can like
it's
for sure but like as an atheist i have
mormon family members um
and
i have known people who are part of the
mormon church
who were
drug addicts terrible people
stealing like abusing each other and
then
found the church
and became
effectively moral people even if it's
something that i don't think
is related to the relig again as an
atheist
it still is an institution that
gave them the motivation to put their
lives on track
there's a difference i think i'd love to
see that without the religious
that would be amazing
sometimes it's not enough motivation
i think well so well that's a that's a
separate thing but i think i think if
you could create the sense of community
and caring it's also very and i i i hate
to be mentioning america but like it's
really interesting when you walk around
america how much of like the
infrastructure for like the safety net
of society is actually created by
churches in america which is a very
american that like outside of america
like the government will step
local government will kind of step in
and help people a bit more um not to
bash americans but it seems to be that
that weight is carried more by the
religious groups in america there's
elsewhere that's why
as a tangent to insert with that that's
why
um in the more conservative states that
have
that typically vote for less
social safety net programs
um statistically like when a hurricane
katrina type thing happens and they look
to see where donations are coming from
to support they actually those states
tend to give
especially via their churches their
church fundraisers and things
they
there's a strong correlation of them
being also
like i don't know if they outperform say
california or something um you know it
gets probably difficult to calculate but
i know that there's a lot of folks that
do believe strongly in those safety nets
but you see the church and then you see
the church doing all those great things
you see the value and you you care for
religion a lot more actually kind of
explains a lot of evangelicalism to me
actually that kind of that's an
interesting aspect well there is
the nefarious side of it though which is
like the the the the
the uh church of scientology is
exceptionally guilty of is
that that off that safety net that is
being offered is actually an evangelical
platform and they it's it's about going
to people in their most vulnerable hour
and essentially saying
you know we'll help you out and sure
would be great to see in the pews on
sunday in exchange kind of thing and
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot of
scooping up now again i don't want to
cast too broad a stroke although i don't
mind saying that broadly of the church
of scientology i mean they bought they
full they full-on told you suicide no
scientology is real they bought a
suicide hotline it was something like
that a few years ago they basically
their whole thing is they don't believe
in psychiatry right so they're really
interacting with people they don't
believe in psychiatry
yeah i think psychiatry is like an evil
con yeah there's a whole oh oh
i don't i don't even want to get the
angry mob in my direction i have no
problems with scientology and would
never want to cast aspersions on
scientology and the people
it's their stated it's their stated
belief that that psychiatry is evil and
manipulative they have them don't they
have like a fake museum in like
california about the evil history of
psychiatry and of course like any
medicine psychiatry definitely has had
dark moments and it's progression
obviously uh which they like to linger
on and talk about but the other aspect
of what you just said alana that i
wanted to come back to was
i don't think it's what you're saying
but this idea of like the the yes
there's community in the church yes
there's these things but this idea of
like morality being something that's
specifically tied to mystical thinking
is something that i've always kind of
had a real issue with as well like
because
humans had humans knew right and wrong
before they
in my opinion made up religion like
there's there's there's a there's is
there there's an old pen and telegraph
oh no sorry no it's a pen it's hot pen
and teller it's just uh just uh
uh pencilette isn't it there's an old
gag from him which is uh religious
people tell ask me um what's to stop me
from killing anyone why can't i kill as
many people as i want to and to which
his answer is i can kill as many people
as i want to i want to kill no people
though yeah obviously like because he
has yeah he has killed as many as he
wants i've killed as many as i want
yeah he's a better writer
he's killed as many people as he wants
to definitely think there are a lot of
like immoral things
or a lot of moral religious people and a
lot of immoral stances that different
churches take my question is more
if people
believing in something is the path to
them becoming
quote unquote better people subjective
is it inherently bad even if the thing
that is making them a quote unquote
better person is not true um and to also
add to the
the mormon thing so again i know people
who converted to mormonism and like save
their lives flip side um when my grandad
was dying had dementia in church he was
a mormon his whole life gave virtually
all of his money to the church was a bad
dad to my dad because he was just so
obsessed with the church
um
as he was dying they came to him and
complained that he hadn't given any
payments to the church and told him he
would be going to hell he dedicated his
whole life to mormonism and then when
he's on his deathbed they're like [ __ ]
you going to hell because he wasn't
giving them any money it was it was
infuriating to witness like his whole
life and they were like no done don't
care didn't didn't visit him didn't help
him like nothing just demanded money it
was terrible
that's horrible question that is that it
was [ __ ] infused
i wanted to beat up a question
i can't i can't answer the question you
asked like the whole like is it if it if
the ends are good enough does it justify
lying to people i
that's a tricky thing that feels like
it's different i'm not saying lying the
the lying is is bad i'm trying to remove
it from the people who are known liars
at these sites well sorry my in my
opinion organizations they don't either
know that they're not a lie
oh if they don't know they're lying if
they're true believers yeah the people
who come knock at your door and are like
have you heard about
the good word of god don't think that
they're lying to you they think they're
healthy no that's true yeah they they
they have a belief and that's different
to lie you're absolutely right i don't
know i think philosophers have argued
over this for millennia haven't they
like i don't know either justify the
means i i i don't know i this is
something i think about a lot um and
um
i think given that we're a social
species
um and we are
deeply wired to think in terms of
belonging in a
group um
i think something that we have found
is that people will organize themselves
into groups
one way or the other so you can like it
maybe maybe my
my church is uh
identifying as a musician or maybe it's
identifying as a as a gamer or as a
professional member of the game industry
and obviously it's the overlap of all
those and many others you find your
tribe to an extent but we all we all
will so so the ability to become morally
um improved and i would also as a side
note
my tangent within this is when you said
mike people knew the difference between
right wrong before religion codified it
i agree with that
to a point but i think that
moral
clarity is a thing that we are
constantly attaining as a species and
there are things
that we consider wrong today
collectively and as individuals and
there are things that we consider wrong
today
that a hundred years ago
um no one had quite realized were wrong
um as to stun people in the streets
yeah and people would go
uh i mean there's somebody
that and and
you know
that and exactly like jim crow
there are lots of people alive today who
lived on both sides of that uh and and
and and many other comparable things and
you know i think that
so so i would say
in the right zoomed out way of like
right and wrong i think there is an
intuition about like fairness that that
i mean they've witnessed this in
chimpanzees you know where they'll
they'll give uh
they'll teach chimps a trick and they'll
give like a banana to one in exchange
for the trick and not to another and it
sees it get a different prize and loses
its [ __ ] because it's not fair but if
they're treated equally they'll they'll
behave more calmly like so intuitions
over right and wrong stemming from an
idea of of equal treatment and that sort
of thing are is not even an exclusive
domain of humans so i just wanted to add
that in there that right and wrong
is it like to me the you know well i
think obviously your whole life like i
used to if somebody would knock at the
door and do the have you heard the good
word of the lord
uh as a very obnoxious teenager who was
one of those i was very like i was one
of those uh religions like a dick yeah
one of those proud gods illusion waves
down your throat or whatever just like
very angry about religion existing
but then
like i came to a point where i was like
the people knocking at my door who i
previously would have been like [ __ ] off
how dare you i was like that they do
think they are helping me they are they
are spending their time coming to try to
help me
why am i getting this mad at them even
if i don't believe what they're saying
will help me um so i point there being i
think even on our own lives we have
scales of what we think is good and what
we think is bad and it's a learning
experience the whole time
and i and i think it's really worth
being i i went through the same arc i
had a very
you know like there's the notion of
being an atheist versus an anti-theist
and i i would have absolutely identified
as a like you said waving my dawkins and
my hitchins yeah and i i think that's a
that's a stage isn't it i think i feel
like every baby atheist goes through the
smug kind of i'm going to tell everyone
i'm right kind of phase and i hope so
that's process i like to think i think
everyone does i think it's
in the same way as most like most
religious folks will go through like
you hear a lot from like i've got you
know my friends who are religious went
through like a very zealous phase in
their teens where they were like
absolutely like obsessively passionate
about religion and now it's faded into a
part of their life you know what i mean
like it's
up and down makes sense that to me is
the key to the compassion of you know
like when you watch debates
uh about religion
normally what the the the the problem
that the atheists always fall into is
they
will
represent the religion in a way that few
of the believers actually adhere to you
know like when we talk about it
when we talk about the stoning of
non-believers and we talk about i mean
this obviously something that muslims a
billion plus muslims deal with more than
probably anybody but christians do as
well where
you know take taken to the letter these
religious texts are full of absolutely
horrible thing
things
of which most of the believers don't
consider
it to be like this thing you have to
follow yeah because the quran is the
letter
oh they're both
they're both full of
i mean they're both aggregates of
accrued thoughts of people over hundreds
of years and they're going to reflect
the full range exactly there's there's
even within the new testament in the you
know
jesus meek and mild there's plenty of
things that make him look like a radical
and warlord and in it alongside
the
you know the compassion love thy
neighbor give to the poor
uh and it's like and so
what i find is
modern christians increasingly
filter out the parts that to them feel
clearly morally vacuous and all this
seems to be all
religious trends and the ones that the
ones that take these really hard line
kind of
ultra literalist stances invariably
become fringe and minority within the
religion and that's one of those things
where
i i to to your question i say
religious
gatherings that add meaning and
especially add social structure to
people particularly when they struggle
like if there's a community and someone
loses their house they get laid off and
the members of the church rally to help
them get get up on their feet and all
that it's like
i would support that kind of thing and
i've i would help i would attend those
services i would do anything
to help those kinds of people when it
becomes a question of
is all of that predicated on a thing
it's known to be to make them not true
well that's to your original question
that kicked us off on this of like the
thing i i definitely agree i wouldn't
call it a lie but i i i personally would
rather
i think that it there is
there is harm that can be lurking
in building your belief on a thing
that is not true even if it's rarely
actualized like most of these people
say i
will pray
that my cancer is cured
but i am also going to go to a doctor uh
like most
most will make that calculus and so it's
like right
the belief that
the belief of it not being true
i mean the rather the belief in a thing
that is likely not true
um or at least to to be mostly can be
super healthy
decide not to go to the doctor
yeah and those people are actually
pretty rare so that's what's that's the
thing that has led me
to really be a lot more
um compassionate plus
what i've found is
you know the
humans we do have a tendency of a of a
religious instinct and and if i had the
choice between a charlatan
uh politician or or cult leader whipping
up people and leveraging that tendency
versus people just continuing their
family tradition of
going to church or whatever i'm like
we've seen what happens when people kind
of reject those more long-standing
organizations and get swept up into the
long-standing ones is the original cult
leader died so they've so they've moved
away there's more i'm not saying that
just to be glib like that a religion
aging
will have exactly the effect you're
talking of usually trending towards
moderation reformation over time um and
that will that will help cult cults are
by definition any more more erratic
because they have a head a person who's
in charge it comes back to as well the
the thing of um the two arguments of
like should you should you uh
spoilers for any plea anyone who's
listening to this in the car with
children first of all don't listen to
this in your car with you whatever but
also maybe
pause or skip for ten minutes
the thing of whether parents should uh
should do the santa myth at home right
like should you tell your kids that
santa exists should you play along with
it should you do all of that it's
definitely something that atheists
discuss and there's two schools of
thought one is
no you shouldn't because you shouldn't
teach a child to believe things without
evidence or any kind of foundation in
reality you should you shouldn't lean
you shouldn't teach them how to have
that magical thinking there's also a
school of thought which is you should
absolutely do it so they can find out
that
old people aren't to be trusted and that
stories can be made up
and there's both of those that's
actually a lesson it's theories
of thought that says it's just a bit of
fun that it's a bit of yeah it's a bit
of of letting their atheist have fun we
don't know atheists don't have fun sorry
we can't be allowed it's all gonna be
very serious and smug i'm afraid but i
like the idea of like teaching a kid
like there are gonna be things that you
learn from me as a parent
which are not going to necessarily be
true they're going to be things that i
believe maybe or things that are going
to be untrue or societal or whatever
like training a kid to kind of question
the reality that's put in front of them
everything that happened before they
were born that's an interesting
that's a good lesson i think that's that
creates an inquisitive mind hopefully i
got kept out of religious studies in uh
high school because i asked questions i
wasn't even really rude about it um and
i went to a catholic primary school um
my mum did not have my sister and i
baptized because obviously my dad's side
of the family is mormon there's a lot of
pressure for that but she was like no
we'll let them make their own decisions
so i went to a catholic primary school
where i was treated poorly because i was
not baptized teachers told me i was
doing your journalists notepad asking
questions right pretty much
and so i in high school i came to high
school where again i had been bullied by
catholic teachers because i was not
baptized camden high school did
religious studies where they actually
told us about other religions um
very interesting to me now that we never
once learned about islam
everything else you learn about hinduism
everything else
no no mention of islam whatsoever
but in any case i just asked questions
and i didn't i i actually probably was
an [ __ ] but i don't recall being an
[ __ ] about it because i know that i
could have been and i was like i'm not
i'm just gonna ask questions
i got removed from the class i was no
longer allowed to take religious studies
as a class uh it wasn't like get out of
one lesson it was we are pulling you
from this entire piece of curriculum for
asking questions and so i never learned
anything about religion ever again
because i asked too many questions in
classes
well that's also it's an interesting
thing in the uk i don't know if this is
true in america but in the uk or in
australia um
when
when i went to school it was called
religious education and before i went to
school it was called religious
instruction which is a really
interesting breakdown of how religion
has evolved as part of the british kind
of education system is you start with
instruction then it moved to education
way we could mention other religions but
we definitely had like there was a there
was a correct answer basically and then
to studies where it's like you know now
it's actually more i think more
egalitarian but that's an interesting
thing growing up um in a country with a
state religion and the differences that
does to your education you know because
henry viii and berlin was really hot
i always remember
i don't know because i was at a public
school
for high school
well in the as a colony
well you would have been in the
commonwealth wouldn't you yeah you would
have been
is do you does that mean the queen is
the head of your religion yeah she's
head of state probably yeah but would
she be the head of religion as well
probably right
i remember once seeing an interview with
richard william was really hot
to be done um can you imagine how hot
she was anyway it happens and there was
an interview i saw with richard dawkins
where he
said
um
there said why do you think america with
freedom of religion is so much more
religious than the uk which has a which
is so atheistic and has a state religion
and his answer was well because it's a
state religion everyone grows up in and
around it it it it's kind of like it
it's it's like
when you it's it's like a teenager
discovering drinking if it's presented
as a forbidden fruit
uh they're more interested but it's so
ambiently and generically you can't
claim it's the underdog can you yeah you
can't say like really they're cancelling
christmas and all this stuff yeah
exactly it's just so boring around
americans
uh some americans um
think i guess
versus being from a commonwealth country
is that they they think that they have
god-given rights and that
certain government scriptures were
written in part by god
like they think amendments were written
by god and they that's why i don't know
anybody that thinks that the amendments
were written by god
it's your god-given right to have a gun
uncommon
phrase that's different that that stems
that stems from the the enlightenment
era political philosophy that basically
says
governments can only limit rights their
rights pre-exist the government oh so
it's the opposite of what i'm thinking
they they use they use the language of
the time would be these rights are
god-given but it but it just simply
means at birth
you have
the right to do everything and then the
government takes the list of everything
literally like think of pure anarchy
zero rules then the government's job is
to codify the subset of things within
that that you cannot do like you cannot
murder blah blah blah but all things
uh s
god given which so that god given
to be self-evident right yeah it is it
isn't it is more of a figure of speech i
i would okay there are people who think
that uh
there were i mean
government scriptures written in part by
god that literally yes
some of these things were written with
god in the pen um that does exist but i
don't imagine it's very many people it's
like probably not but there's a really
good watercolor of like the founding
fathers they fully think the founding
fathers
like that that is a thing that i don't
think anyone in
what's the artist in america who draws
like pictures of like american
politicians with like jesus like putting
their hand on the shoulder of donald
trump or something i swear i've seen
those images that's what yeah there's no
there's no question that that there
would be there would be some contingent
of
cause the there's no like a lot of the
the
founders were
you know not all of them were
especially religious and
even the more atheistic ones were really
more kind of deistic and not really
atheistic they weren't they were just
kind of like god probably exists in some
amorphous sense but
you know it's not christian conception
of god they they they weren't really
atheists in the don't worry about him
yeah exactly clockmaker type god uh
beliefs but yeah but um get on with life
and do other things basically but the
idea of natural rights is the is the
notion that that government's principle
positive rights and negative rights are
basically uh the idea of of
governments function is to limit
behaviors versus the government enables
behaviors and the fundamental concept
behind all of american law is the
government can only limit behaviors it
cannot it cannot enable you have the
right to do everything pending
legislation to the contrary
in reaction to some other culture but we
don't need to think about the history
what about the twelve commandments are
those not restrictions
twelve commandments ten sorry
it's been too long i mean
for the record i think there's like 400
something actual commands they have
amendments too commandment amendments
they have amendments too are we talking
about amendments are we talking about
the constitution and the amendments or
are we talking about the bible talking
about the bible and the commandments
because aren't those
the biblically laws like that that would
restrict you from doing things that
would impede on your god-given right
well only the u.s constitution is making
the argument that rights are god-given
and uh and uh the government's role is
to limit from does it say that the the
bible
uh
is gonna say that
um
well that's a good question i would have
to see i would have to see the the uh
say one nation under god right i've
spent so much time reading about the
the i've spent so much time reading the
political analysis uh uh i actually have
a copy of the constitution almost in
reach i have my microphone get it let's
name this let's do this
michaels
i i think um
what do i think what was i gonna say i
feel like it's every twenty episodes we
have a reason for my father some reason
it's good though the comments are gonna
be so freaking about constitution and
declaration wow
i'm not gonna be able to read the whole
thing but um please control f your brain
to find the word god yeah exactly do the
thing with matrix the the the downloaded
like in like neodys yeah
uh but point being the the uh
the
political
framework of it the the philosophy of
governance that it outlines is
absolutely one of negative rights
in which
um the the uh the like powers of the
government are those which are
specifically enumerated and nothing else
implied which is the whole reason why
there's you know court system that
argues over these things in a way
from the marvel the default state is
complete and total rights but the bible
um i can't i can't speak with any real
authority about the bible but certainly
with anything beyond that
like you can't wear mixed fibers in it
this stuff to do with cutting your hair
it has plenty of rules
yeah and and and the i think the the
political philosophers of the time would
have essentially argued
um
that the the that there would be further
things that your religion beyond what
the government is restricting you like
for example the government can't tell
you what to eat but if your religion
your religion instructs you to keep
kosher that just means that within the
subset of i'm allowed to eat anything i
want
my religious personal beliefs will
narrow that field in an opt-in i choose
to be part of this religion kind of way
and and the and the and certainly the
u.s government would have no issue with
the idea of people limiting their own
behavior through personal involuntary
associations uh but it's just outside
the purview of the government to
restrict that people and the interesting
stuff happens when one contradicts the
other right when when your rights as an
american citizen
are
different than your rights or
your rights can impose upon the rights
of another with their religious beliefs
and your religious beliefs and that's
where all the more reason why fun
interesting stuff happens yeah and all
the more reason why keeping religion and
government you know uh separated um
it was all the more less ambulance
really hot and then
the um the the thing that i always love
that that kitchen coming together it's
beautiful kitchens always love to point
out in his debates is when talking about
uh thomas jefferson in vote and you know
coining the phrase of a wall of
separation between church and state
the original context for him having done
that if i remember correctly was not
about the idea of
religion guiding governmental policy nor
government encroaching on religion but
it was actually um
uh two real two religious communities
essentially
sort of fighting for a an area and and
being unable to wield the government to
oppress the other as and and saying that
the government can't be made a tool you
know tyranny of the majority was always
one of the big concerns that's why this
is a constitutional republic and not a
straight democracy is because it's very
easy to whip up public opinion on
something and then just overtly
tyrannize the minority and they knew
that they they designed the the to as
many checks and balances on the
structures of power specifically to
prevent that among other things and one
of those is religious minorities you'll
end up with a community of people that
are way outnumbered by the rest and and
they shouldn't be under the boot of of
those who would wield power on use
religious
grounds to do so they have no legal
backing as a result which to me is an
incredibly enlightened
way to to to structure your law you know
it like the idea of of of of um
opting out of the maximum amount of
power
um out of a defense of the minority
obviously the u.s has gone through
is our aspirations
governmentally and constitutionally are
often above and beyond our reality we
don't always live up to those ideals as
a country we often don't but uh but i do
think that the essence of that idea is
something quite
uh brilliant uh you know it's held it's
one of the it's held longer than most
single kind of governmental structures
hold so it's it's obviously doing a lot
right like a couple hundred to me the
the hope always stems from the fact that
it is a democracy theoretically
most very few very few
like democratic
governments have lasted
250 years my understanding was actually
the us act has lasted the longest it
might be the longest
i'm trying not to say that you meant
that it was like the longest
type of government but democracy's
changed a thousand times
over
no but it's like prior to democracies at
some point
reborn or fascism
there's a
strong and quite alarming political
theory that fascism is the inevitable
result of democracy interesting which is
a fun note for this podcast yeah no it's
true i mean but but that's the thing
absolutely like that is interesting
well in terms of historical precedent in
terms of like what has happened what has
actually happened every time democracies
it makes sense
that's the whole reason why
representational republic
tries to put a barrier
so that pure populism can't be co you
know
used as a as a kind of evil to me it's
always very interesting and the thing
that always gives me hope i don't really
ever i'm not a i'm not really a believer
in nationalism uh which means that
patriotism never doesn't really fully
make sense as a belief because it's like
like the whole manifest destiny and all
that kind of stuff that's you know
everybody's
yeah exactly and even as a kid that
never that never clocked as anything for
me you have to do the pledge of
allegiance every day
i didn't realize that was it you that
tweeted that recently alone yeah i
replied to somebody i think about it a
lot it's [ __ ] terrifying no i replied
to someone i've never thought about that
every day they have to pledge kids
but for what it's worth it's always
treated
it's the equivalent of having good
manners or something it was never it was
never it never felt i imagine it's it's
just a chore for kids you just like i
get up and i do the thing but it's still
things you have to think about i totally
agree if if i could stamp my fingers and
not have those kind of indoctrinating
rituals to me i i absolutely think
they're
they're uh weird especially because as a
kid i very you know early on
my my dad who was an atheist was always
very encouraging if i ever wanted to
explore religion he's like i'll take you
to church i'll take you to synagogue
i'll do whatever you want to do if you
are curious
um i am not religious but i would never
get in the way of you exploring it and
so that being the context of my
childhood it did feel weird to have to
say under god even as a little kid i
thought that was i thought that was odd
but it was it wasn't offensive or scary
so much as like oh huh yeah that's a
that's an odd 20 seconds to my dude i
don't imagine it's defensively
the dawkins take on religion right the
dawkins take on like like national
religion like it's kind of so ignorable
by kids that you kind of yeah but it
still sets a default it's still yeah and
there's no question that it can't not
have an effect to say
words
like that a thousand times uh you know
what i mean like you can't
but all i was going to say the only
point i was driving towards with whole
nationalism and patriotism thing is that
while i don't really
buy into that as a belief system it's
never really felt descriptive of me the
one thing that always does leave me
baseline optimistic about
the us
uh is that that the system has baked
into its you know those self-correcting
mechanisms so that as the population
becomes more morally enlightened or
becomes more
uh diverse from a more global world with
more a better a deeper melting pot of
of immigrants from around the world and
all that that the the the
the system endures and actually
like on boards these different belief
systems and is designed to flexibly
um adopt you know adapt them um adapt
for them
and so you know even you know
even as there's still always so much
work to do to be
to be what it
aspires to be in its documents
it actually has the ability to achieve
that without burning the entire thing to
the ground i know there's a lot of
people that would disagree with that
argument and think that the system is
irreparably broken and i'm always
open to being wrong and i just i hope
they're wrong because i i think
it is a remarkable
endurance of of
you know this country's had some
as dark as people think it is now it has
had some
insanely horrible periods in the past
and actually managed to like be the
better on the other side of those things
and i think you know that's
that's pretty encouraging it it
that that that that system we're not
[ __ ] perpetually you know what i mean
i would like to believe i again i don't
want to overly i'm sure the comments
will say i'm rose-colored glasses and or
don't know anything
i don't know enough to defeat you
honestly so anyone in the comments who
wants to just jump in the comments and
like just compliment like
austin's hoodie or something that'd be
lovely just some nice stuff because i
can imagine something i was gonna say
i have to go but i was gonna say because
we've we've done like i said every like
25 episodes or something we end up
talking about religion somehow for some
reason um
i'm sure there's plenty of stuff that we
don't know
we do not pretend to try to educate
people or be experts on anything other
than our vocations on this podcast
it's the point is conversation we're not
trying to tell you anything about
somebody we're three idiots in the pub
at the exactly
kind of wish they'd be a bit quieter yes
you are just listening to three people
having a conversation with not
pretending to be knowledgeable or to
inform you
none of it no i that's what i love i
love that that we
all of us actively google things during
the course of the show at one time or
another because the the whole point is
not
uh
uh
speaking from some pulpit of of of
authority but actually going hmm i
wonder let me know hold on let me think
it would also be a much less interesting
podcast if we were afraid to
explore any idea that we weren't 100
educated on so
apologies we don't know [ __ ] we just
like talking i don't think you should
apologize for it i i'm
as people have often noted who see me
lurking about in the comments uh in the
days following the release of a new one
i check it every you know 18 hours or so
i'm like i'm curious what else is going
on there
um nothing pleases me more when someone
can like link to an article that says
this is what contradicts the claim you
made it totally three seconds or
whatever and it's like
they show exactly i i will i actually
have a browser of all those articles and
i and i haven't haven't read any of them
they're just all there
yeah you click the link in the little
box
it's my equivalent of steve and happy
madison
writing yeah i block every user that's
criticized me not even criticize just
correct it
um all right no criticizing i do have to
run thank you for joining us everybody
i'm alan i'm a video game writer that's
us getting to reading
that's mike bittle he's a video game
director troy is still busy off in the
world and we'll hopefully be joining us
soon we're very close to 100 so
i hope you can join us yeah we got to
think of what we're going to do i put
the bat signal out i've got a feeling
it'll come back figure it out all right
bye